right now the value of women is lower
and lower we're offering less kids less
Purity less youth
um we it's very on it's very rare to see
women actually serve men
um when uh you when you ask a question
to a couple typically you see the woman
answering instead of the man
um indicating that she's leading the
relationship um instead of the guy when
you look at more traditional
relationships you see the woman looking
to the man you see a man being publicly
disrespected you see wives looking like
on Instagram this is common and
not every woman will do it but we don't
acknowledge women's nature and we also
see women that were quote unquote good
women and that did things the right way
let's let's say the Stephen Crowder
thing they will waited till they were
married got married after a couple
months on both Christians and it seemed
like that was the right path and yet
women are women